ich bin fast tot
diese tasten minecraft freunde
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
captain microsoft zwei mit dem
contractor nachdem die musiker nach dem
vier stunden live stream den ihr
wahrscheinlich an ihr euch jetzt denke
was vielleicht überhaupt ihn
wahrscheinlich verpasst wir haben
gestern vier stunden lang des triemli
wie captain gespielt haben und wir haben
einiges geschafft das seht ihr
vielleicht jetzt nicht auf den ersten
blick aber wir haben beispielsweise es
mit dem skelett geschafft wir haben das
mit den acht herzen schaden geschafft
wir haben unten einiges verschönert wir
haben ja naja also die verschönerung man
muss sagen es ist noch alles rein also
es ist noch oberflächlich gewinner ich
habe auch gesagt ja damit wir wollten
natürlich auch eine karte geben wo wenn
ihr hier lang glaubt wenn ihr bock habt
dass ihr dann auch sehr okay da ich weiß
noch wie kundschafter hier damals in
dieser ecke verreckt ist oder oder sonst
wo weißt du dass man da unten bei diesen
bei diesen nenner ding wo ich komme mit
die acht herzen abgezogen habe da vorne
oder wie hier mausi gestorben ist wenn
jetzt nicht mehr gesehen habt dann ja
ist allerdings genau dieser friedhof
leider sehr schön aus aber jetzt wisst
ihr auch wenn die map bekommt und wir
werden das jetzt mal schön machen würdet
ihr gar nicht wissen dass wir diese
beiden bäume abgebaut haben und das holz
zu bekommen für die bücherregale um
unsere böden zu verzaubern weil die
haben jetzt auch alles ausgebaut und
dahin hatten wir ein netter farm und wir
haben uns für den netter vorbereitet 14
vorbereitet und wir sehen hier
wir haben hier direkt heilungs tränke
zwei wir haben hier ist acht minuten
stärke tränke wir haben hier
unsichtbarkeit tränke die hat eigentlich
nichts bringen wir haben gold äpfel wir
haben einen kürbis wegen den andern
männern wir haben wir zu essen ich hab
dem thema da muss man ein feuerzeug man
falls zehnte bringt eigentlich gar
nichts oder das einfache kürbis auf ich
glaube dass tnt bringt gar nichts oder
einfach für seine aufgaben wird so schön
aussieht bringt nicht viel bringt
eigentlich gar nicht was das ziel die
davos ist
hab ich und das wichtigste wir haben
stärke bogen dass das wichtigste und die
köpfe einen körper ja dass hier wir
haben uns extra live stream gesagt viele
wollten dass wir da schon sein kann aber
wir haben gesagt für alle die beim
leitet mich dabei sein konnten
machen wir es jetzt nochmal hier für
youtube und jedem jetzt quasi nach unten
und das team war wirklich total genial
wirklich richtig geil noch mal danke
fürs zuschauen dass er alle dabei war
der wert dabei war es war wirklich sehr
cool auch die ganzen tipps natürlich
muss man sagen es sollen wir wirklich
wirklich richtig viele sachen dabei wie
zum beispiel beim bildschirm könnt ihr
euch völlig aus oder einfach ihren
passat oder einfach auch irgendwelche
sachen ja das skelett ist irgendwo es
ein verstecktes porno außerhalb den
müsst ihr finden und über die world
order darüber klettern und alles nicht
irgendwo her okay weil eigentlich musste
man einfach auf dem set platte drücken
und wenn man wenn wir an diese challenge
denken mit dem skelett
der ersteller von cap tiff minecraft hat
uns geschrieben habe ist er etwa als ob
es nicht schon damals highlight walter
hier geleistet hat
obwohl es wahrscheinlich im land rover
bei hat uns geschrieben im chat wie man
denn dieses mit dem skelett macht und er
war wirklich dann wie es auch
beschrieben hat mit druckplatten gut die
war nicht aber auf jeden fall so weiß
überhaupt wo du langen muss war doch
oder
ich werde dies auch weiter setzt auch
schon frei gesetzt ob es hier bei dem
überlegen wenn wir drin sind wir beide
müssen erstmal die kristalle auf diesen
riesigen ob sie dir hier ist überhaupt
das ende aufgebaut du bist ja erstmal
der spezialist passte also erinnert
rache der holt sich immer die energie
die das leben von sich selber von diesen
obsidian türmen denn oben drauf sind
solche kristalle die sieht man auch
eigentlich weil der enr drache immer so
eine art verbindung zu den hut auf jeden
fall musst du eben diese kristalle diese
auch leuchten werden
die musst du abschießen damit halt da
nicht mehr ran kann diese chance
abschießen oder hoch bauen und abbauen
nicht abbauen den abschnitten ab schießt
mit den pfeilen und das möglichst
schnell wieder halt kein leben mehr
nacht bekommt und dann irgendwann gehen
wir halt auf den drachen darauf dass
aber der letzte schritt eigentlich wäre
es denn sinnvoll das bmbf
end drin sind dass wir uns dann quasi
erst mal mit cobblestone so ein bisschen
was so bauen also beispielsweise dass
man erst mal keine baseball oder so das
ding ist der ändert rache macht alles
kaputt glaube ich so weiter informiert
wenn der charakter des zubaus wie kaputt
machen das weiß das bringt eigentlich
nicht viel
und das wird eine tolle pace bau dann
ist direkt kaputt genau das problem ist
wespen auf einer insel wir müssen über
so eine art insel jump n run auf die
hauptinsel rüberspringen das total
gefährlich ist das heißt es kann
passieren dass ist gleich einer
innerhalb von drei sekunden tot
prib feiert mit ich liebe wachsen wieder
er findet direkt tot das ding ist jetzt
überlegen wir haben diesen über heftigen
goldenen apfel ich habe keine ahnung wie
lange der held aber ich glaube wenn also
ich meine die rüstung wird er noch nicht
komplett direkt zum anfang entnehmen wir
wissen halt überlegen wann nehmen wir
den übernehmen wir die normalen gold
äpfel ich würde vorschlagen
diesen duo button ja genau du hast keine
von oder ich habe nur zwei ganz normale
gold äpfel habt ihr ja gut dann geil
dann würde ich vorschlagen ist hier der
boss du musst das irgendwie alles machen
also stärke brauchen wir noch nicht wie
gesagt wir gehen jetzt mal im bogen auf
die kristalle rauf und dann also erst
mal auf die hauptinsel angekommen okay
ich mache mir schon mal unsichtbar und
nicht die beste idee die wir hatten
sind deine habe nicht okay
kraft hatte ich muss auch meine rüstung
anziehen ohne helm okay okay okay weil
wir rein wollen wir rein leute ich
glaube wir wollen rein
ich habe ein künstler nicht auf ich bin
fast tot
diese tasten weg weil ich mir war das
gibt's doch nicht kontrollieren
wieso du bist du bist du
komme wo bist du ich bin und wo unter
laub ich sehe dich du bist wieder um
durch die appelle und junge männer da
ist wo hier der verdacht laute auf
laufen wo es ja schon pass auf und jetzt
müssen wir leben an die er gebunden
er kommt schon von hinten muss auch was
aufgeräumt auf du musst hier oben dass
man eine featurette hier oben schwimmen
auf der oben sind die teile drauf da ein
habe ich zwei relativ auf den habe ich
schon die termine an wir müssen jetzt so
schnell wie möglich sind dabei hoch
schießen da oben drauf und damit und wie
ein treffer wie wo siehst du denn nicht
jeder kleine teil lassen musste
hochschießen einfach schon wieder ich
habe schon jeder schuss ein treffer bei
mir ich wieder eine alte bäume hier ab
tatsächlich will noch mal hier war kein
tier habe ich wahrscheinlich um
ausgelöscht doch ich mein getroffen ja
ich habe einen getroffen
wie viele gibt's davon weiß ich nicht
genau als michaela trafo noch kein mal
angegriffen ich mag mich gar nicht doch
doch der branche in der nähe guck mal
hier oben in deiner ganz hinten ließ der
mann kommt gar nichts mehr an er geht
nur zu dir hin silberfische silberfische
alt oder was sind das für teile der
inhalte ist bei mir ein wenig
wegschubste nicht mit dem goldenen äpfel
sparen im ruhig meinen goldenen apfel
ich habe nur zwei ja dahinter hat mich
auch gerade angegriffen
ich habe gerade eingenommen ok du musst
immer schon wo fliegt der eintracht auch
hin
wegeleben regenerieren ingo wetter
immerhin fliegen nur ein glaube ich
geburt
insgesamt übernimmt das was gerade
anstrengend ist und man wo ich kann dir
keiner kommt hier so jetzt mussten wir
hätten betten mitnehmen können dann
hätten wir ihnen damit springen könnt
neu bestimmt gefährlich sind vor sich da
oben jetzt mal hoch zu bauen an ihren
dann kann er runterschubsen ja wir
müssen noch einmal schauen hast du speed
rang
nee du mal dieser bringt nix ledig
meinte sehen kannst du ruhig machen
damals alles legal also ja wir haben
glaube ich keine glasflaschen nur noch
wenig nach erwartet kein leben mehr
jetzt ganz eigentlich wenn er kommt
drauf gucken wie ich gerade jetzt müsse
einfach kommen am besten kannst du dann
macht das mit stärke ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher aber ein turm hat er noch
mehr stärke trank ich ein rein ich habe
immer jetzt richtig der stärke dann
bringt es verbogen machst du mit drogen
und ich warte bis du oder ich mach ein
bisschen mit besteck gemacht ich hoffe
er kommt jetzt schlafen bin ich in die
arme so jetzt aber hier in die fresse
oder der war gut am besten jetzt nicht
schießen genau selbst gar nicht schießen
will bereits weit weg ist da trifft man
nämlich wirst du nicht und man denkt das
sollte eigentlich schon schaffen alter
das ist ein eigentlich doch relativ easy
ja jetzt schon wir sind ja auch gar
nicht mal so schlecht ausgestattet also
in summe das läuft das risiko ab der
andere nach gelesenes direkt auf mich zu
geflogene bringt man aber der heilt sich
irgendwo ich weiß gar nicht wo da hat
sie sich heldt um herkomme konflikt
wohin glaube ich was ich immer wir noch
dran hält
und der war gut der war gut der war gut
da war gut leben
genau das schon sieben minuten stärke
geil hinterher laufen zudem änderte
hinterher muss im blick halten da oben
fliegt entlang
ich hab die rapper anteil der kranke
einem zugeworfen der bringt zwar nichts
aber kommt er wieder glaube ich auf dich
aber nicht doch zu halten
das ist auch schon natürlich hier das
ist schöne sache jetzt es ist irgendwie
so jetzt bin ich richtig gesteuerter
aber das krank ich habe mich so viele
herzen schaden genommen habe ich sehe
noch relativ schlecht immer durch diese
blöden kürbis da ist komm schon ich
kräfte mit dem schwert auch gar nicht
ich treffe die manchmal mit dem bogen
jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt aber du mit
der du mit einem bogen verscheucht sema
so ein wenig auf ja aber das macht nix
ensemble geschäft gehen stimmt eine
stärkeres mit schwert sinnvoller als
jetzt gerade
ok jetzt ins team einbauen dann
ärgerlich gekommen einander nicht mehr
buchen das mal warten bis dahin kommt
auf unsere sie mit dem spielen ja mit
dem schwert werden extra stärke tränke
macht der kompakten auch komme ich
möchte nur einmal nämlich schwer treffen
okay okay dann warten wir jetzt mal wir
stellen uns am besten beisammen kommen
jetzt relativ hoch doch jetzt kommt auf
uns wie wichtig die ihn richtig ich habe
ihn einmal getroffen
ok ich weiß nicht was mehr schaden macht
das schwert glaube ich also ich hab hier
sperrt du nicht ausversehen nicht einmal
getroffen
du sagt kommen wieder her
durch dieses eine weg schleudern alt hab
ich immer ganz schön leben verloren
fällt mir dazu auf wo ist da das
sommerkino ja du hast ihm zwei schläge
über gegeben sehr gut so einfach nur
noch ein viertel der leben leute dass
ein paar das ende von captain wir sind
wir haben täglich bis ins erdgeschoss
das aircap tf1 nicht geschafft an das
heißt ein cap dreist das ziel erstmal
dafür überhaupt schaffen weil die map
hat mega schwer ist jetzt aber jetzt
aber okay jetzt habe ich ihn noch mal im
fall getroffen
wie könnt ihr vielleicht auch wer bei
der bundeswehr so bin ich gleichzeitig
schießen dann kann man zwei mal treffen
ok spannen an spannenden bogen okay ich
bereits 21 ok doppel getroffen das
machen wir das diesmal auf abwarten bis
er wiederkommt spielen voll mit dem
bogen spannen 3 und 2
ihr werdet abgewendet habe jetzt zwar
okay noch einmal noch einmal krass ich
hab noch 14 pfeile das heißt es war gut
dass ich da mit 26 32 12
da kam ihr zu nahe hier irgendwie
internet einfach nicht mehr so viel
leben schäfer wir christen vergessen und
er legt sich gleich komplett einfach auf
wir können ihn nicht attackieren
ich schieße noch die ganze zeit nahezu
abnehme treffer und ich wie viele fehler
das war
108 11 modus machen 51
ja das ist jetzt viel schöner da ist das
ende
wie schön es ist einfach in der luft
er ist als die ganzen ich bin level 55
47 alter und da oben drauf sind ja auch
noch ein paar links ich hab kein stein
aber ich habe doch gar nicht hoch bauen
nicht ich kann nicht setzen bis hinab an
hier zeigten immer ein und danach ein
und wir machen wir nicht dahinter warten
erst mal googeln schon drin
das 1 0 erzielt sich gericht die krise
wie die hre
und warum berufe und bronze schön ist
dass minecraft logos stehen minecraft
skeptisch aber hersteller geschafft
comedy und contractor haben das lange
abenteuer erfolgreich abgeschlossen
glems kann auch einfach geschafft ich
dachte wirklich einer von uns beiden
wird noch sterben nicht weil du spielst
dann anfang der veranstaltung
guck dir mal meine aufnahme an ich bin
in den neckar ich bin ja eher später
eingegangen dann als du schon drin fast
erwartet der schreibt einnahmen konnte
hat meine polnischen thomas e nein ag
kann sein comeback
in feldgemüse letztendlich so erwarte
ich muss in meinem kürzlich wieder push
up platt wie sonst was hier so rein
während ich so drin rein importiere soll
quasi höre ich nur so
ich denke ich bin fertig so fakt und
natürlich so rein und dann fehlt dieser
ender drache auf mich zu ich doch es
wird nie mehr dass wir sterben beide und
das klappt nicht aber das hat richtig
gut geklappt muss man auch ehrlich zu
sagen aber der anfang war wirklich ein
wenig hart weil ich bin über diese
inseln ruhige gesprungen und
wahrscheinlich als du dich auch
plötzlich teleportiert hast gab es
diesen lag halt bei mir dieser komplette
lecker sind steine das ja auch dazu beim
jump n run total bekloppt und ich bin
einfach runter gefallen und jetzt stelle
mir vor ich wäre ein blog vorher so nach
dem motto runter gefallen weil ich
glaube ich gestorben und in der
unendlichkeit gefallen aber ich habe es
geschafft
das ist das recht muss echt sagen jetzt
mal ich mach das jetzt mal ganz gut so
das kann ich immer ganz gut zur revue
passieren lassen und zwar also was jetzt
hier erfolge angeht haben wir eigentlich
alles geschafft haben und zwar einmal
diese rose target dies aber einfach
damals kaputtgegangen weil die in diesen
fluss runter geschwommen ist in der
höhle balkankrieg anderer die rose
altwegg und damit haben wir dann halt
das pinke achievement das pinke moment
noch hingekriegt und durch das pinke
moment haben wir zum beispiel die
schweine bekommen durch die schweine
haben wir dann wieder nicht gemacht also
quasi alles nacheinander aufeinander
aufgebaut und dann haben wir als halt
gesagt wo wir quasi an der stelle
angelangt waren okay wir brauchen jetzt
noch clay und biss noch das machen und
da müssen wir noch warten auf das
zuckerrohr da müssen wir noch aufpassen
das warten haben wir dann gesagt wenn
man den livestream haben dann vier
stunden geschrieben den kann man sich
bei dem auf der twitter-seite glaub ich
sogar noch anschauen wenn man eventuell
machen ja die ein oder anderen
abonnenten suren best oft davon beweisen
in paris kommt dessen symptome sind vier
stunden live stream die wir einfach
gemacht haben und das hat eigentlich
meistens drücker relativ gut geklappt am
anfang ein paar problemchen mit skype
und blabla aber das war aus st das
gemeinsame live streams oder das ging
eigentlich und die sache ist halt quasi
bike exif minecraft die ganze zeit um
diese ski fans und ich muss echt sagen
ich bin stolz auf uns also wir haben
jetzt alle achievements geknackt die man
knacken kann
außer dass mit dem gas wir haben uns
echt alles hingekriegt alles obwohl das
eigentlich gar nicht mal so schwierig
ist man konnte sich mal schnell das heft
minecraft 1 luisi hingekriegt ich nicht
du natürlich aber bei mir war es wieder
so auf einmal spornt das direkt vor mir
also ja ich gesagt du hast es dann auch
noch geschafft weil das war doch gut das
war so witzig kleid also gleich noch
nicht sicher kommen kein gas auf ein
maßband gas und hier und da nicht nur
eine sache die ich meine du wirst nicht
gleich sterben gehört wurde dass man das
tut sich was kommt der anruf links
runter und
herrlich herrlich also captain craft ist
wirklich eine tolle gaal also hat man
glaub ich auch daran gemerkt dass wir
einfach durchgehend jetzt schon seit
zwei monaten oder so cap tippspielen und
das bedeutet dann schon wirklich was ja
ja ich hätte drei ist jetzt auch draußen
also ein paar youtube arbeitet auch
schon kräftig drei angefangen also ich
weiß dass roth bis das jetzt schon macht
hat also ich will nicht sagen dass weder
so ein bisschen angefangen weil er
lieber besonders ja auch schon da
aber es ist schön dass die karte so
richtig bekannt wird und dass die
entwickler dadurch also sofa lenders die
sind auch mega korrekt also der hat uns
ja der hat ja unseren live stream
angeguckt hat uns im live stream
geholfen wenn ihr das anders machen
wollt macht ist und die ist so richtig
will
und ja ich find's ganz cool dass dadurch
die karte so ein bisschen bekannter wird
dadurch bekommen die vielleicht auch
motivation noch mehr so was machen und
das ist in richtig coole idee so etwas
mit einer world browser zu machen
richtig cool denn er macht er auch immer
wieder was neues
ja als ich das macht das ist ja das neue
mit dem 1.8 update mit dem unterwasser
trainers werden wir glaube ich sehen
oder wir wollen müssen nicht alles von
hand auf dem motto wir wollen auf jeden
fall was kann ich schon verraten würde
sind willig aber vielleicht kennen das
auch schon einige aber trotzdem
wir werden es spielen denke ich mal aber
dann wissen wir nicht genau aber in
nächster zeit ja wir wert kraft wenn wir
morgen direkt wieder anfangen würden
deswegen ihr werdet schon sehen wenn
irgendwann die folge kommt vielleicht
können wir würdigen wir das irgendwie
bei twitter an vielleicht auch nicht wir
müssen wir mal gucken auf jeden fall
damit beide bockau skeptisch drein und
ich hätte auch mega bock auf captain
vier wenn er noch mal was kommt in der
arena wüste oder keine adresse hat
mercedes extreme rat und tat
na ja gut ich will auf jeden fall daran
captain 2 fand ich richtig cool weil
einfach alles geklappt hat wir haben es
immer abwechselnd hochgeladen wir haben
die falls ich fand es einfach super
eigentlich glaube ich hatte noch nie so
viel spaß gemacht dass man ja auch
gerade richtig also wirklich war ein
hammer geil das projekt hat spaß gemacht
auch diese abschluss jetzt normal war
natürlich der hamas wäre
noch mal gepackt haben es war es war
kurzzeitig spannend so als ich
reingekommen bin in einer band und ich
hätte fast das wird schon nicht
geschafft kritisch wenn es euch auch
gefallen hat könnt ihr das ganze jahr
durch einen daumen nach oben da lassen
und eventuell noch mal eure erfahrungen
mit diesem projekt reinschreiben
eventuell was findet ihr am coolsten an
diesem kniff zwei playlist blabla oder
was fandet ihr so am traurigsten
bestimmt viele leute die den livestream
gesehen haben deswegen ist es auch
normal ist eine beschreibung verdient
komme auch da will ich sagen ich bedanke
mich fürs zuschauen wir uns denn in den
nächsten tagen wochen irgendwann bei cap
33 leute hat mir auch sehr viel spaß
gemacht und ich denke mal konkret da das
gerade alles perfekt beschrieben kann
ich nur die worte weggenommen
blablabla ganze durch redet ist kein
problem
du hast eigentlich alles perfekt
getroffen und ich will auch sagen jetzt
an der stelle des westens video ja ich
bin gespannt auf den nächsten teil der
karte und ich hoffe mal als gefallen
also haut rein und schön mit